okay I have video of death cult
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis
he defiantly and courageously has
announced no matter what Joe Biden says
about vaccine requirements and what
employers should do in Florida if you as
an employer require vaccination you will
be fined five thousand dollars this guy
is going backwards on just about
everything the crowd cheering we have
Clips we have conspiracies we have
everything let's get right into it this
is Ron DeSantis yesterday saying vaccine
requirement fines not vaccine
requirements fines for vaccine
requirements here we go and so if a
government agency in the state of
Florida
forces a vaccine as a condition to
employment that violates Florida law and
you will face
now you know sycophantic cheering aside
this is really muddled because the Biden
requirement is for employers over a
hundred employees DeSantis is talking
about state government agencies
requiring it to work now the Biden
version has an opt-out which just
requires a weekly test so it's not even
really clear that this is a direct
response to the Biden requirements it's
just the DeSantis mess
foreign
for every single violation okay so this
is
um you know the the party that says
never regulate business business should
be allowed they are now starting to say
no let's actually regulate business in
this case talking about state government
agencies rather than businesses but he's
been pulling a lot of the very same
stuff then going on to talk about
um booster shots so-called booster shots
some calling them third Doses and again
just so hyperbolic so sycophantic here
we go can you imagine if Trump had
unilaterally set a date for FDA without
their having underlying data I mean the
corporate press would have a meltdown I
mean it would be wall-to-wall hysteria
now remember Joe Biden talking about
September 20th is the date at which
people will be able to go and get third
doses be able to go and the idea that
there's anything tyrannical about that
is just as silly as the idea that
there's anything tyrannical but any of
the things that have been done so far
him perverting uh science and not
following experts or whatever and look I
have no knowledge because I've not seen
any data but these booster shots but it
could be in a situation where what six
months from now if fauci says get one
you just have to do it are they going to
fire you then at that point are they
going to fire you a year from now okay
um Ron DeSantis then continuing on and
then giving us some scenario about
forcing an 80 year old to be vaccinated
pinning down an 80 year old you know
there were some that just did not want
to take it they did not think that it
was something that was right for them
and so what are you going to do you're
going to pin down some 80 year old
nursing home resident and force them to
take it they had whatever reason I don't
know what what the reasons were whether
a doctor recommended whether they had
had covered before what have you and so
it just shows that
um and I also think that what they're
doing is very harmful yeah
um this guy's completely out of his mind
I mean it it is a death Cult of sorts I
don't even know quite frankly that
DeSantis believes this stuff I think he
knows he's playing to a cult in Florida
and he'll be punished if he doesn't do
this stuff here's a clip I actually
can't tell if this was the same event or
not let's see look he's wearing the same
suit although it might be no I guess it
it's the same room the lighting is
different here an anti-vaxxer was
invited to speak
stood behind the Seal of Florida
and said the vaccine changes your RNA it
doesn't and DeSantis just stands there
the vaccine changes your RNA so for me
that's a problem so I I'm here with you
folks we don't want to have the the
vaccine it's it's about our freedom and
liberty it's not about the vaccine yeah
so I mean okay DeSantis looked a little
bit uncomfortable with that but when he
spoke he just thanked the guy and did
not mention anything about the fact that
the vaccine does not change your RNA
does not change your RNA I don't even
think the guy speaking knows what that
means so a complete death cult
continuing to control Florida
unfortunately let's make sure that a
similar death cult doesn't take control
of California by voting no on that
recall tonight one of our sponsors is
Magic spoon breakfast cereal sweet and
tasty like the cereals I loved as a kid
but without the sugar or the carbs every
serving of magic spoon has zero grams of
sugar only four net carbs 140 calories
and packed with 13 grams of protein
perfect if you're doing keto perfect if
you're doing low carb great if you're
just trying to reduce your excess sugar
intake and because it's packed with
protein it's great before or after a
workout magic spoon flavors include
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry and cinnamon They're bringing
back cookies and cream They're bringing
back Maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all magic spoon
is so confident in the product if you
don't love it as much as I do they will
refund your money no questions asked go
to magicspoon.com Pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code Pacman at checkout